Kevin Millar here on the show how are
you Kevin Britt you what's up brother
what does Yankees Red Sox robbery mean
to you sir right now it's so much better
when both teams are good you know it's
not as fun obviously when one teams good
the other teams not there are teams
trying to rebuild Yankees got good last
year last six weeks of the season and I
think they tend into a really powerhouse
and a lot quicker than I thought these
young guys would be so now the rivalry I
think is getting back kind of what we've
wanted to see over the last few years
because it lost a little mojo and and
now you're looking at two teams are
probably 100 plus games well you know
when you were playing with the Red Sox
Kevin it was the the situation where
both teams are good and playing for
quite a bit when when it was time and
looked you're professionals you get paid
a nice chunk of change to play the sport
and it's a great that you put on a
uniform every day which it's a dream of
every kid to do something like that but
when it all comes down to it did you
have a dislike for the Yankees was there
a different sense in the locker room and
in the clubhouse when you were getting
set to take on the Yankees Kevin yeah
you know what it's a great question
because as a player the city's the media
the ownership they battle right but
there's there's also a respect when you
go in between the lines and when you had
a chance to you know play and compete
against a Derek Jeter you know in Jason
Giambi and Roger Clemens and Mike
Mussina and all the stuff at Bernie and
Jorge there was a respect when you cross
lines but it seemed like we were in some
kind of turmoil every single time we
played it was like the Super Bowl of
baseball and in that that you know no
three oh four no five the rivalry was
just it was he did he was heard we were
so opposite you know to the Yankees we
were shaved heads with full Mane's and
beards grungy you know guys along here
where the Yankees were a clean cut they
were tall and they were rich and they
were good-looking we were bad bodies so
it was just one of those things we're
kind of like we played that underdog
role even though we had your man
Americas and poppy turned into poppy and
to Curt Schilling but it was just more
of a rugged type you know
city and team in Boston then the New
York English who's at 26 you know tennis
at that time and I always said this
wasn't a rivalry this was a slaughter so
we have to win one to make this a
library and obviously you know for it
came so what was what was I guess the
the most the boiling point while you
were with the team with the Yankees like
I can pretty much guess it but what was
the biggest boiling point Kevin you know
what I think the game we had rain the
entire day and night before and they
walked the field in Fenway and wanted to
basically cancel it to kind of get the
rotation going you know I think they
wanted you know when I say they I think
ownership at that time upstairs whoever
makes the call was like listen we have
will have Pedro and and and showing it
however they wanted to set it up and o4
but we were we had Bronson Royals
starting tonight and we went into the
you know Franco's locker rooms but
basically is like eight of us now we
want to play we're playing tonight and
even though it didn't match up perfect
and you know when you play the red sauce
Anke Joey want the eight BC when Coleman
whole shabang going and we always wanted
you know our top three rotation guys but
we had so much confidence in Bronson
royal he was such an underrated starter
for us but we went out there and that
was the night that the a rod and the
Varitek fight happened he had some other
breaking ball and then that happened and
then Billy Miller you know end up you
know getting at home on three learn how
money is Mariano Rivera and we end up
playing the game that night and it was a
huge game because we were stuttering
around four or five hundred but I said
we want you know two games that day we
won the fight and we won the game but it
also it just was our turning point I
think one when we kind of just like it
put us on the map like let's roll you
know and sometimes bench-clearing brawl
czar kind of part of baseball and they
lot of talking and chit-chatting but it
also can bring a team together and I
think that was the one one when Alex
kind of looked at bronson after getting
hit by a breaking ball like oh no no no
na and that's the obviously Varitek
thing and we had a nice broth
honestly I would thought you'd go Pedro
and Zimmer Kevin I mean that was that
was pretty big dude honey that was oh
three now and that was a Pedro if those
it's obviously a high an amazing inside
it was just off the plate high and then
our mayors and Clements that they're
barking wolf that dogs ever since Pedro
Martinez were hated by the Yankees right
I mean he threw up and then it was he
was good and it was a lot of years of
dominating that that team they obviously
didn't like it but Don Zimmer came
flying across the field and Pedro our
hands and Chris cranny who is our
trainer walking on a dugout and dog
shark Pedro and to be honest with you
when it first happened everybody was
like what I just throw it all back down
and that's Don sever and everybody loves
dogs ever but you know Stan he kind of
stepped aside and kind of just you know
push them to fight push them down
however you want to say it in a
situation that really was at Pedro's
even involved in that yeah I know it's
just it's amazing how raw it is still 15
years later - Kevin and a rod a rod in a
booth on Sunday night for ESPN I mean
it's very easy man but it's still raw it
really is on both sides it Kevin it's so
it was such a honestly God it feels like
it's yesterday and like you said you're
looking at 15 years ago but those
rivalries those games I mean I still
think of any the excitement in the
cities and the towns and we would go to
lunch in New York and fans are flipping
us off and yelling at us and you know
it's awesome in the buses you know we
drive to you know Bronx and the buses
and they new is the Red Sox [ __ ] bus and
their fingers going up you loved it when
you were in that house in the old Yankee
Stadium there was a nice thing said and
I'm gonna say right now at Fenway Park
you're warming up to that bullpen
there's not nice thing said if you
weren't pinstripes in that great uniform
so it's kind of what makes a rivalry
nice you know as the fans get into it
and there's a little bit there's a
little bit of anger there Kevin Millar
MLB Network here on the Rich Eisen show
and again you know it's interesting
obviously Aaron Boone who hit that home
run in O 3 in game 7 he's now the
manager of the Yankees we talked to Dave
Roberts multiple times out here on this
show you know his stolen base in 2004 -
part of that comeback
for you guys to break the curse he wears
that there's no matter what the hell
he's doing with the Dodgers he wears
that as a source of pride and he should
forevermore what we see from that 2000
305 era where you were playing there -
is it possible we're seeing that again
right now
Yanks Red Sox right now Kevin yeah I
think that I I think the the the the Joe
Kelly fastball to Austin started it we
remember the slide in the Bronco they
got into it a little bit but we finally
get a little emotional you know I think
these teams and these guys are so nice
they really are I mean you meet
energizes the sweethearts and there's
such good kids Ben and Wendy and JD
Martinez that's you know but it they
really are there's this nice kids but
you need some edge it was like Chris
Sale kind of has that edge you know for
the Yankee snap I don't know who has
that address but you just you got it all
of a sudden it's like Joe Kelly here we
go we're a little brawl okay and then it
was like Erin judge moved the entire
both teams off to the signs of guys have
done like nobody wants a fight judge I
get it he sticks every should be points
I don't help you kind of felt it so like
I I like that there's a little fire now
yet alicorns don't have any toast Babs
there's a little fire and they're both
good so these names mean some because
it's so important to win this division
this isn't about trying to get in the
playoffs it is so important that one of
these teams win their division cuz you
are guaranteed that by game series I
want you president anything could happen
I love it they are nice guys and you
just see in that seeing that fire in the
belly right I mean just seeing that
thing go and and I I do find brawls
ridiculous especially when when
relievers run 300 feet in from the pan
and they just you know don't even get it
like it's just what are we doing here
but just you know again I grew up on
this stuff I grew up on on Bucky Dent I
grew up on when's immer was the manager
of the Red Sox right I grew up on Billy
Martin and Reggie Jackson fighting in
the dugout in Fenway Park I grew up
on Carlton Fisk and Piniella going at it
I grew up on this stuff and I'd lot and
I've got a nine and seven at home I kind
of like it's awesome you know I kind of
want to show it to him it's it's the way
it you know and I told Tommy out yes
he's unwritten rules I don't ok to throw
up and I don't know you know what more
fun baseball you I go Chris you can do
whatever you want on the baseball field
you can you have the right to do a
backflip a 3-2 home run backwards
there's just repercussions for your
actions period end of story
so there's a way to play the game
there's a written rule to play the game
that's like sigh you might be drilled
pimple homerun you might get drilled
right not it just depends on what goes
on there was just always that edge when
all robbery is there you know just that
edge just a little edge never knew what
truck Wilson was going to do a Roger
Clemens ideal or Pedro Martinez was
gonna do you just was there and then you
know it's nice to see there's a little
bit of an edge somewhere in this rivalry
because it's been that's been very
friendly and huggy and sweet and
everybody's just you know good good old
man all the guys and now we're now we're
okay we both got this call twins and
poker the powerhouses of the of the big
leagues along with the Astros and let's
roll man we're showing some old footage
right now we're shot we're showing
Fenella going into Fisk and here comes
nettles we're showing that right now
it's just awesome
before I let you go Kevin who does have
the edge out of these two teams going
into this series and and for the rest of
the season based on the rosters as they
currently stand yeah currently Stan I
think both their bullpens closers are
studs Chapman and Kimbrel so you can
just check a mark there give the
advantage to the full bullpen of the New
York Yankees their lights out then
awesome all year suck for the Yankees
their power wise well I tell you JD
Martinez has finally come in the middle
of that lineup and now for you you know
you don't have that Big Papi boy I think
the Red Sox have had that poppy boy no
matter how that they've been scrappy
wise last year but it's best at 40 an
hour and 120 they have that now with
Jerry Martinez looking best turn into a
so three four you can do a wash
Yankees are more intimidating long ball
one through nine so give them an
advantage they're starting pitching of
the Red Sox
honest to god record could flip a coin
it's it's going to like more and that's
who's gonna win but in this series I
would give that I would get the edge to
the Red Sox you know you get sale yeah
Rodriguez tonight's sale and price in
the cities and then they have separate
oh they're like what a 2-1 year eight
twelve and two at the back end but Sonny
gray I don't know who the real Sonny
gray is you know with Oakland we saw a
glimpse of a spell lewdness with with
the Yanks it's been a high pitch count
guy he's been a guy that kind of throw
straight in that times but he still has
great stuff and great command cc's
doesn't get enough credit tonight so
we'll see what happens he's pitched
unbelievable and learned to pitch what
he's you know he's given with that
backdoor corners and changeup not that
95 inside with that that great slider so
I would give the edge to this series I'd
give it to the Red Sox that are playing
better right now
overall flip a coin but it's gonna be an
awesome race it will be great
we'll see it tonight Game one on MLB
Network and say hi to Chris Rose when
you do intentional talk with him later
at 5:00 Eastern Kevin great chat that's
Kevin Millar the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience